en compétition les meilleurs mondiaux
peuvent propulser le volant à plus de
450 kilomètres heure c'est dire la
rapidité du geste et de ce sport
j'essaye de pages et sur l'adversaire
pour le mettre en difficulté
et dès que je sens avoir l'ascendant je
finis le poids
mathis fait partie des espoirs de la
martinique
champion régional junior ces deux
dernières années il est aussi depuis
l'âge de 14 ans surclassée en seniors
son point fort le physique et il en faut
pour cette discipline très cardio pour
être un bon badistes avant tout il faut
de la technique pour ben ça va renvoyer
le volant et après quand tout le monde
dans un niveau savoir l'envoyer là où on
veut l'emmener ensuite il faut du
physique
donc là on parle des qualités de
déplacement pour arriver le plus tôt
possible sur le volant pour qu'on va
prendre l'ascendant plutôt dans les
changes ensuite il faut bien la tactique
comme tout sport il faut une stratégie
de jeu et puis après le sûrement le plus
important le mental son adversaire du
jour c'est jean christophe sombou
aujourd'hui parmi le top 3 de la
martinique
il a découvert le badminton grâce à
l'urss depuis cinq ans il fait partie de
la sélection régionale et vient
d'enchaîner trois titres de champion
antigua yann mon point fort un mois ça
va être le jeu au filet comme on voit la
précision
c'est un sport qui m'a plu parce que
j'ai envie de dire tout le monde peut
s'exprimer aussi bien ceux qui ont un
gros physique que ce qu'ils ont
un gros mental une
grosse tactique on va dire donc chacun
avec ses armes on va dire peut gagner le
match en simple en double hommes dames
ou mixte les joueurs peuvent s'enchaîner
jusqu'à huit matches par jour lors d'une
compétition un rythme qu'il faudra tenir
d'autant que pour sa cinquième édition
le prochain open de martinique monte en
niveau
cette année on a des gros joueurs qui
viennent
de métropole on a
cinq six joueurs de niveau national ils
viennent donc ça c'est assez
exceptionnel on n'a pas l'habitude
d'avoir ça donc c'est bien aussi pour
les joueurs de badminton de martinique
parce que ça nous permet de voir du haut
niveau des niveaux qu'on n'a pas
l'habitude de côtoyer canada belgique
haïti guyane et guadeloupe en tout plus
d'une centaine de badistes
s'affronteront sur trois jours de
compétition